[Music]
good morning honolulu
this is wake up today on khon channel 2.
all right diana okay ron a new traveling
exhibition looks at health and medicine
among native hawaiian people it's
actually made up of various ipads which
is why i got mine
that display the native voices of hawaii
discussing health and wellness
the national library of medicine's
native voices native people's concepts
of health and illness exhibition
continued its nationwide tour by
visiting hawaii
its first stop was the queen's medical
center in downtown honolulu
where the grand opening of the
exhibition coincided with queen's
heritage day
this year's theme of na leo ouivi
literally translated as native voices
coincides with the opening of a
traveling exhibit from the national
library of medicine
it is here in the queen's historical
room that these native voices
will permeate our hallways much as the
king and queen's voices do today
the heritage day celebrations began at
mauna ala
the royal mausoleum where honoring gifts
called hookupu were presented at the
tombs of the hawaiian alii
or royalty the celebration continued on
the queen's medical center front lawn
with presentations by local
and national dignitaries when we stop
and
reflect for a moment on what these past
155 years represent
the queen's vision that is still being
carried out
today it's truly an inspiration
in the queen's historical room kupuna's
medical staff
and hospital visitors listen to the
stories of the native voices exhibition
each of the indigenous peoples has a
unique culture
unique heritage that is melting away in
the 21st century
what native voices enables is the
preservation of a culture
and through the telling of their story
enables everyone else to share and
appreciate
what the unique values that the
indigenous people
have provided to this country to this
land
in our culture it's very important to go
back to the communities
that you get to know and i think it just
highlights the
commitment that the national library of
medicine and the national institutes of
health have for the hawaiian people
the native voices exhibition will also
visit the university of hawaii's john a
burns school of medicine
and the hamilton library at the
university of hawaii at manoa
as the native voices exhibition travels
the national library of medicine hopes
it will contribute to positive health
outcomes in native communities
throughout the country
i'm hoping that with these stories
something will change
maybe prospective students healthcare
providers
or the hawaiians themselves who would be
the patients
my hope is that they change their
behavior in terms of health to live
healthier lifestyles
what the native voices exhibit reminds
us all of is that
you are accountable for your own health
and it's one of the main things that
we as hawaiian people take very close to
heart
without health you don't really have a
community and so i think
this exhibit helps highlight those
facets
of traditional culture that makes us
think of
what legacy am i going to leave for the
next generation
you